- You've had your image
on movie posters altered a few times
And I love that you've spoken about this
because I've had the same thing done to me
like on magazine covers or album covers
And I have no part of it.
Like, I'm totally fine
with what I look like, like
it's usually, like, I don't
know how to use Photoshop,
like I don't even know how to Zoom.
I, my assistant has to do it for me.
Like, so like, I don't know
how to do any of that stuff,
but does it bother you when they do that?
It bothers me.
'Cause I'm like, why are you so offended
by what I look like?
- I was just like you, Kelly.
I was on a flight.
I was on the flight the other day with,
well when I last flew,
which is over a year ago,
but I was on a flight with
this guy and I, and I, and I
took a selfie and he
looked over my shoulder.
So when I didn't know, and
he said, oh no, no, baby
you got to face tune that.
And I said, sorry, what?
He said, you got to face tune that.
That that was my introduction
to the world of face tuning
which I then realized has often happened
to well body tuning.
I definitely, for the
poster of Johnny English
my breasts were augmented.
in the poster the kind of character shot,
I've got like a very impressive chest,
which I, I don't have.
(laughing)
And, and, and for Radioactive strangely
they made my eyes brown, which
I still don't quite know why,
sort of brownie hazel color.
So it's, it's odd,
but then I was thinking about it
and I was thinking do we actually know,
those are the obvious times, right?
When, when you do notice, you're like,
oh, I've got brown eyes or
I've got massive breasts,
but they're probably
countless times where,
you know our image is doctored
and we don't notice it because, you know
I think we're all losing a grip
on what we really look like.